now many years ago I discovered that
there are 31 Proverbs when you read the
book of wisdom in the Bible written by
Solomon there's 31 of them which makes
it fairly easy to read one a day so if
you don't do anything else in your
spiritual walk or in your search for
wisdom you can read one proverb a day
and if you do that over and over and
over 12 times you will have read that
book in one year right and 30 years
later I have read it a bunch of times
and I you know proverbs this book of
wisdom and I you know what if you
actually understand the stuff you will
get wiser in that interesting you know
and here's what happens when you get
wiser your life gets better because you
quit doing stupid stuff you know I have
figured out the less stupid stuff I have
the better life I have you know that's
fairly some point in it you kind of get
back what you put out you reap what you
sow if you plant corn corn groves if you
plant stupid you grow broken desperate
you know you're gonna get a crop of
something in your life what's your crop
gonna look like right for instance
proverbs 10 says a slack hand causes
poverty but the hand of the diligent
makes rich translation lazy will make
you poor and you work and you'll have
money
it's not a hard translation is it a
slack hand causes poverty but the hand
of the diligent makes rich interesting
diligent what is diligence diligence is
excellence overtime
continued excellence not one moment of
excellence but continued excellence in
ordinary things when you do ordinary
things with the level of excellence
that's called diligence and by the way
that makes one rich interesting isn't it
the hand of the diligent what's the hand
the hand of the diligent makes one rich
so here's one of the things I figured
out I read this study years ago and now
I've observed it in all the millionaire
we meet with and talk with and and it
showed up again in this millionaire
study the Chris Hogan and the team just
did for the everyday Millionaire project
you know we interviewed ten thousand
millionaires and one things we found
there and one of the things we found in
this study before that that I read years
ago was people who have wealth and keep
wealth and build wealth have a long-term
planning window when they're making a
decision about an action a purchase
something they're going to do they think
to themselves how's this going to affect
me five or ten or fifty years from now
and they make decisions based on that
they buy a car based on that rather than
based on Mithu okay people who are broke
live woohoo thank God it's Friday oh god
it's Monday
they have a short planning window it's a
it's an emotional immaturity that can be
it for a 55 year old or a 15 year old I
don't care but if you have a short
planning window you are on track to be
broke if you're broken you have a
long-term planning window you're
starting to think like rich people and
if you think and act like rich people
you get to become rich people a the
diligent hand the hand of the diligent
makes you rich
so we're thinking long-term so an
example that is I've noticed that rich
people have wills and poor people have
fights when they die over nothing
because they don't have anything but
everybody still fighting like a bunch of
hillbillies you know we're just gonna
have a big redneck fight here mama died
and we're gonna fight over her three
things that she had on the windowsill
you know because there's no will so long
again you think long-term and so like
wealthy people start thinking about
stuff like retirement and how I'm gonna
pay for my kids college when the kid is
born not when the kid graduates from
high school it's not like woohoo Oh God
right
it's like babies born we're gonna start
planning now you start thinking long
term that's how this works
and so our team is gonna help you with
this because some of your listening
going okay I get that but where do I
start
well we're the specialists in saranya
where to start at anything whatever it
is you want to do we're gonna show you
where to start so we built a 5-minute
coverage checkup that shows you ten
things you need to do to think long term
to make sure you have the coverage in
place do you have your long-term
thinking dialed in I'm going to tell you
one of the will right you know will and
do you have your long-term thinking
dialed in ten things you need to do
coverages you need to have to make sure
you're in place the right insurances
check your credit report getting a will
you can take this whole little you know
you can go in here and check that you
can do the whole thing and find out
exactly where you stand in five minutes
you stand in line to get bad coffee
longer than five minutes so don't think
short term think long term go take the
little five minute quiz and you're gonna
find out where you stand the ten things
you need to be thinking long term to
take the take the five minute coverage
checkup a checkup from the neck up baby
that's what you need now if you're
missing something
I'm at a port to point you towards the
pros that I trust you can do it or not
do it I don't care but if you hear one
thing don't put this off protecting
yourself and your family is diligence
and remember the hand of the diligent
makes rich so here's what you do you
wanna do the five minute checkup you got
to the five minute coverage checkup all
you do is text the word checkup 33 789
checkup 233 7 8 9 or if you're not a
text whiz like me which I hear these
text things I don't even know how to do
that crap okay but I do know how to go
on the website right and you can just go
to Dave Ramsey com
slash checkup now that one I can do or
just type in check up in the search bar
and you'll find it on our website okay
you'll find it it's okay
it works out so text check up 233 789
doesn't cost a thing that's completely
free we're just trying to get you guys
going man you just need a place to start
you need the 10 things to do to be
thinking long term because if you think
short term you're just gonna be broke
that's what amounts to you guy think
long term think like rich people rich
people think in five and ten and twenty
year blocks of time poor people think in
ten minute blocks of time if your whole
life is a woohoo oh god that's gonna
make you poor you can't do what God
thank God it's Friday hoe gaat it's
money you can't live your life that way
and the way to break that is to start
looking out longer-term with all your
decision-making and this is a good place
to start the 5-minute coverage check up
text check up to 33 789 or go to Dave
Ramsey com slice check up it's free it
takes less time than getting a bad cup
of coffee do this people this is the
Dave Ramsey show